good morning
welcome to this mid-suffolk overview and
scrutiny committee meeting
i'm councillor keith wellam and i'm
chairing the meeting today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave please ensure
your mobile phones
are on silent or switched off
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
and not to post comments or questions
please note that messages in the chat
panel can be viewed by people watching
the live broadcast
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
we move on to the introductions i i'll
now ask the governance officer to carry
out the introductions please
thank you chair um the cabinet members
present today um is a councillor
whitehead
um cabinet member for finance we also
have officers
we have the assistant director for
corporate resources
the assistant director for housing
corporate manager financial services
commissioning and procurement and the
finance business partner
thank you chair thank you
can i move to the agenda then please
um at what point then are we carrying
out the roll call are we going to carry
out a roll call at this point
um yes chair if you wish
yes please okay uh counselor terence
carter
presents counselor james caston present
counselor paul eppkin young
president councillor dave mullen
president council key scarf president
and councilor willem present
so can you note there are no minutes on
the agenda today
as they were agreed at the joint
overview and scrutiny committee
in june 2020
and we're all present there are no
apologies received
are there any declarations of pecuniary
or non-pecuniary interest
by members please has anyone anything to
declare
are there any petitions have we been
notified of any petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme please
uh non-chair thank you
and are there any questions by the
public none
sure received
and are there any questions by
counsellors please
none receive chair thank you
can we now move on to item
mos 21 draft
general fund budget for 2021
22 and the four-year outlook
and i'd like to invite councillor
whitehead the cabinet member for finance
to introduce the report
uh thank you chairman um yes i'm pleased
this campaign financed
for the opportunity to say a few words
of introduction
to the draft general fund budget 2122
and the four year outlook
when we met last january here to
scrutinize last year's budget
we little imagine that our whole world
would soon be changing so drastically
by the pandemic and that our finances
would be coming under such
unique pressures our initial projections
of the effect of the pandemic on our
council finances were horrendous
but since those early days central
government has been extremely generous
with their assistance to local councils
helping us to minimize the impact of the
pandemic on our finances
and some of that generosity will extend
through to the end of first quarter
21 22. there are a lot of details within
this budget report setting out the
financial
impact of kovid 19 and the present
economic environment in which the
country now fans itself
you can see paragraphs five sorry
paragraphs 4.5
through to 4.18 for the details
so the government is rightly focused on
responding to the public health and
economic emergency
along with being engaged in the
protracted brexit negotiations
and this has resulted in them having
limited time to raise their sights to
the future
and accordingly they've just announced a
one-year spending review
and they've put in place only a very
short term fix
with new homes bonus they'll soon be
starting a consultation on a future
replacement for new homes bonus
and they have delayed the fair funding
review
the business rates review and the
business rates reset
and this frankly makes it very difficult
to make any meaningful forecast
beyond march 20 to 22 for our four-year
outlook
in addition the provisional financial
settlement was only announced in the
17th of december
just before the christmas recess in
parliament
and giving us just five working days
before the christmas break
and the deadline for preparing this
report for cabinet
so the details provisional settlement
are included in paragraphs 419-421
but some of the changes are still to be
fed through into our budget numbers
so this draft budget does show healthy
surpluses throughout the four-year
period
but i can't overemphasize how much
uncertainty is built into the numbers
beyond march 2022
the reasons i've just outlined the
budget we approved in february 2020 for
this present year 2021
incorporated an increase in the
mississippi share of council tax
by 1.66 percent in that year
and this increase was assumed to
continue year on year
throughout the four-year outlook and
this draft budget now before you
continues with that assumption
these are modest annual increases which
along with a small growth
every year as new built homes become
occupied
we will be gradually building up an ever
more robust council tax
base to service for the future the
current projections show is raising
six million three hundred and eighty two
thousand pounds from council tax
in this next year increasing through to
six million nine hundred eighty seven
thousand by the year twenty four twenty
five
this year you'll see we're adding again
um one million pound to the commercial
development risk management reserve
whilst we still await planning
permission on the revised master plan
for our major
gateway 14 development before
groundworks can begin we've also added a
further half a million
to our climate change and biodiversity
reserve
provide a serious amount of firepower to
these vital causes
i've also recommended to my cabinet
colleagues and need to seriously
consider further significant additions
to reserves
to cover future planning legal and
planning enforcement expenditure
as we finalize our numbers in february
because i believe it's vital that we can
robustly defend any planning application
going to appeal
i'm sure our residents will expect that
we should deliver on their behalf
you'll also notice to anticipate getting
cifco fully invested by the end of march
2021
and therefore no further capital
investment for yield has been
incorporated into our future capital
programme
and the details of the capital programme
has set out an appendix say
so members i would welcome your
observation and questions on this draft
fund budget report as part of this
important scrutiny process
and between myself and the finance
officers present we'll do our very best
to supply
comprehensive answers thank you chair
thank you councillor whitehead
um do any of the officers wish to say
anything at this point or are you
all ready to field questions
thank you chair i'm happy for us just to
go to questions
thank you very much so now members can
uh ask questions and i'll ask each
member in turn
if they have any questions and can i
come to councillor paul
ekmanyon first
uh please you chair um
i don't have any questions at this
moment in time
thank you uh councillor muller
thank you chair i too have no questions
at this moment in time thank you
right councillor keith scarf do you have
any questions
uh well just one actually um under 8.5
we're told that the reverb business
rates is expected in the spring
this year how likely do you think that
is actually going to be to occur because
i suspect it won't occur because
there'll be other issues that will
uh take the government's time and does
that have any effect at all
on us at the moment or do we just keep
going as we are under the current system
thank you um i i
don't really know the answer to that
obviously it's crystal ball gazing um
i don't know if catherine's got her ear
close to the ground with
a national level and i think she wants
to add to that
i was going to say if if the government
are going to want to change the business
rate system from april 22
because they've deferred it from from
april 21 then they will have to start
something quite early on in the year um
i appreciate there are a lot of other
things happening at the moment and
distractions but
uh that's the latest that we've been led
to believe
from the government and saying and if
things start to slip then it does put
the
the
april 22 change daily in in
in jeopardy so um that's what we're
working to at the moment but it is a
watch and see as with
most other things at the moment uh dates
change and
things happen thank you councillor
carter do you have any questions please
not at this moment thank you
councillor caston thank you very much mr
chairman
um in this in this report i can't
um seem to find um much um
growth in the business rates tax base
um am i missing that or is that just
because of the uncertainty that
the council white had talked about in
his um
when he was introducing it and um that
we've talked about since
i think there is a lot of uncertainty
but again i i always refer
defer to catherine when it comes to
business right now
i wonder why councillor whitehead
um at the moment the figures that are in
the report
are the figures that are from our
medium term financial strategy from
february 2020
um we do a return to the government this
month
and until we actually do that return
then it's difficult to update the
numbers
so that will be an area that we will
update for the final version of the
report that goes in in february
um it is a very difficult area to
predict at the moment
but there have been a couple of changes
to the
babe the mid suffolk uh business rates
base in 2021 that will feed
through um there's a new um
i think what it's actually called it's
is to do with the offshore
wind farm and where the grid comes in
just on the edge of brantford there's
been a new rating coming to the system
there which is actually two million
pounds
so that has added a reasonable amount of
growth on certain
amidst of its business rates base but
that's just one element so
until we actually do the return in
january
and submit that to the government it's
difficult to get the precise
feeling for for what it's going to look
like for 21 22.
so say those numbers we will update for
the for the february version
and then comes into into council
okay thank you um
i've got a few questions if i may please
um and really these are these are things
that i think it will be useful for
members to know a bit more about
when we come to the council meeting so
if we look at table
one on page 12
um i i think i know what the
lower tier services grant is is it
explained anywhere what it is
a [ __ ] just come in the chair um
it's a little bit higher up on page
12. there's first bullet point on page
12. there's just a little bit explained
there about it
yeah yes
to be honest there is there isn't a huge
amount of detail
from the government um in terms of of
what they've done
uh i think in essence what they have
done is
the total amount that they had set aside
for
new homes bonus hasn't all been
used in 2122
because they're not paying so much out
now
and i think they have diverted some of
that funding
into this lower tier grant
but they're saying it's a one year only
grant
that's fine thank you very much um
in on page 13 table two
the total underspend of
three million pounds if we add the
transfer
the transfer to the commercial
development risk management reserve
was was that envisaged at the before the
start of the financial
year is or has that come about because
they're because of underspends elsewhere
no the fundamental the mrs i've had this
now for
a couple of years already and it all
really relates to the commercial
uh development risk uh we're undertaking
as a council
and i'd say primarily at gateway 14
where obviously we're
turning a field of sugar beat into a
major industrial park over
you know 10 to 15 year period and the
reality there is that
within the budget as we lend money to
gateway 14
we get income uh interest coming in
well or interest coming into the figures
but the reality is there's no cash flow
at the moment because there's no
cash flow within gateway 14 well the
only cash flow is
money going out at the moment so it just
feels prudent to
sort of recognize the fact that the um
it seems more like smoke and mirrors the
uh
the income coming in than reality until
such time as
that uh project is uh much more
further down the line so last year year
before
and this coming year where um we've
taken a prudent decision i think to put
this money aside um you know until we
can be
much more certain about the outcome so
it hadn't been planned at the start of
the financial year it's
it's it's money that can be put into
that reserve because that money has not
been spent on on other things
yes and we were talking about but budget
going forward so obviously no money
spent at the start of the year but
i take your point and i understand what
you're saying and yeah
yes i agree with what you're saying yeah
um the um the budget surplus at the end
the bottom of that table 2.027
um that presumably goes into various
reserves
correct i mean as i said in my
introduction um
the i i think by the time it comes to
full council in february having spoken
to my cabinet colleagues
we're going to put some more money aside
somewhere around the sort of 300 000
pound mark
into specific reserves for planning uh
legal costs and planning enforcement so
that will bring it down
slightly to the 1.7 but the balance of
that would then go
into the growth efficiency fund
normally do you want anything further
catherine
i was just going to mention that the
table that you're actually referring to
chair is the one that talks about how
the current year's budget
yes has been allocated i say the one
that
refers to 2122
is the table on page 22.
so that shows you the position or the
projected position
according to the draft budget for next
year and at the bottom of that table it
shows you what the proposals are
in terms of how that would be allocated
to different reserves
um bearing in mind what council
whitehead said about the extra couple of
ones for planning that aren't reflected
yet
now i mean the the point i'm trying to
get around to is that
um when we see that figure at the bottom
of that table when we get to council
would it be possible to um to have an
explanation of where that money
is going to be allocated in the into the
next financial year that was
off the top of my head i think the two
million pound surplus for the current
financial year was planned to go into
the growth and efficiency
fund um oh
with the exception of what uh councillor
whitehead has
has indicated yes sorry councillor
eppingmon
so sorry in the table that um catherine
and yourself are referring to on page 22
it does indicate at the bottom which uh
reserve the
surplus funds are going to go into so
you can see for 2122 that
approximately 1.7 million goes to the
growth and efficiency fund
and then there's the one million that uh
councillor whitehead refers to
with regard to the development risk
management and then
a further half a million to the um
climate change
uh initiative so that those where
those funds are going so yeah i mean i'm
what i'm trying to do is to see if we
can make it
clearer to to
to members um when they're reading
through the paper that they won't have
to
for counsel that they won't have to look
elsewhere that that was my only point
well i don't think they would have to
chair because the numbers are there in
the table
in the other table yeah okay
thank you um
so i've got a q a query on page 23
which is to do with um the increase in
service charges for endeavor house
of 43k um
are we likely to have an increase in in
service charges
if we're using endeavour house
less and
is there any likelihood that we would be
able to
if we didn't need it to give up some of
the floor space that we currently
use right i mean
as it says there's this subject to
discussions with suffolk county council
so i
i guess it's put there as a matter of
prudence that we
we've been sort of given the heads up on
that i mean in terms of the uh
the space releasing endeavour house
which is on the first floor and the
second floor
for those that can remember that far
back um they
my understanding is we're sort of tied
into i think sort of five-year agreement
so and there's still some time to go on
that again if captain
can give any more detail or at least
confirm what i'm saying in terms of the
sort of longer-term commitments to
endeavor house
yes we we certainly are uh tied into a
five-year
initial uh four five years before
there's a break clause in
in the lease with uh suffolk county
council
and that lease that we took out it did
have this
increase in service charges so i think
this was a planned
we had lower service charges for the
first three years and then it was
planned
to go up at this point in time but
because of
the position at the moment not
necessarily that we're not in the
building but
because the building isn't being used
and i think some of the the overheads
obviously that suffolk county council
are incurring are reduced
so um chief executive is in discussion
with
suffolk to try and negotiate down
perhaps what was the planned
increase in those service charges yeah i
mean things like coffee and milk i know
there are any small things but they're
presumably included in that and we're
not
we're not making coffee myself
thank you carter you had your hand up
but now it's gone down again
oh yes my hand was yo-yoing up and down
as
question spur being answered as i was
about to ask them
um i do is it possible
then for the service charge to be
reduced from what we're currently paying
as we are of costs
to us well has gone down with us not
needing the facilities so usually
outlook for the next year possibly
yeah that's probably that's probably
around the discussion that i was
suggesting i think
that it's it's still under discussion
but but because we're tied into an
agreement it's not going to be an
automatic
reduction i'd like to think you know
it's it's supposed to be oppressive
transparency there and
the position is that the service charges
are to recoup
costs incurred so we certainly hope that
certainly um
chief executive chief executive can have
this sort of discussions to
to sort of make sure they reflect
reality going forward
um can i turn to page 26 and 27
and i'm just wondering whether that
heading at the top of graph
7 at the top of page 27 is correct
there's
when i was comparing those two
graphs the heading at
the heading at the top of above graph 7
that it runs to 24 25 and yet underneath
the
the bars in the graph it says 20 23
24. um
not i mean not asking for an explanation
now but it
perhaps that could be looked at
yeah sorry i think on the bottom of
graph seven
the the um the numbers sorry the years
there
are actually one year out right it's
gone it's gone through a long
quite a lot of uh scrutiny before it got
to
your eagle eyes keith they're well done
um
yeah so if that should be absolutely
yeah
the the other thing this graph and other
graphs
and when we're comparing one graph with
another the scales aren't quite the same
so the height of 1.083
million at the bottom of page 26 doesn't
appear to be the same as the height on
page 27 so um
and and also on page 24 and 25
the the colored blocks uh on the two
on the two graphs are to a different
scale i just wondered
if they when we come to council
that the the same scale can be used
when we're trying to compare two graphs
this is a reasonable request to me yep
we'll certainly look at that chair
before we present the
the final version and you'll be pleased
to know this is my last query
on page 20 acts 11.1
it refers to appendix b but there is no
appendix b i think that should be
appendix a
unless there should have been an append
i don't think the capital program is
appendix eh
yeah so yeah okay um
so i've i've got no further questions
if anyone else has any further questions
uh councillor
ekpanyong
[Music]
thank you chair um i have a couple of
questions um
if we could go back to just bear with me
a second
scrolling to section
8.
okay so section 8.19
um just like an explanation with regard
to
the section on pension fund assumptions
um
it's not entirely clear to me what is
meant by
the future rate contribution of 23
percent
um and is it fair to assume that the
the pension fund deficit lump sum
that basically means we're not paying
any more money into the pension fund
to reduce the deficit um if you could
please clarify
all right was it the 23 that's the
employer's contribution
which is saying it's staying at this the
same rate
as um this year
is that per per employee then uh
councillor whitehead
that's my understanding catherine can
just
say yeah i mean there is there's more
than one element to the pension
contribution i believe but maybe
catherine can perhaps give a bit more
meat to those bones the the percentage
is the
employer's percent of the basic pay
so the employer has to pay a 23
of the basic pay into the pension fund
so that's what the percentage refers to
if that helps to answer that
question okay then that's
quite separate from national insurance
right yes absolutely
yes okay
and with regard to the pension deficit
london
we are still paying because the um
pension fund isn't a 100 funded yet so
there is still a deficit
payment um but it's getting closer to
being fully funded which means
we're on a slow would slow down with
trajectory in terms of our contributions
so we're making a one percent reduction
over
three year period the pension fund gets
valued
every three years and at the last
valuation
uh it was agreed that we could reduce
one percent each year
say for a for a three year period so
that's what's um just reflected in that
sixty nine thousand pound reduction i
think it's fair to say that beyond what
catherine says i mean there was
has been a coveted impact on the on the
pension fund but
that seems to be being clawed back you
know almost as we speak
so until the next evaluation we won't be
certain but
it does seem that over the time that
deficit has been
closing okay right thank you for those
answers
and if if we're made then on page 24
under it says major contracts there's an
increase in our waste
charges of uh 235 000
pounds could we get some context
to that i mean is that what percentage
that of our current
uh waste contract and
why has it gone up by that amount
i'm not i'm not sure about the uh
percentage of the current contract
um i'll in the background i'll see
whether one of my colleagues
could perhaps find out that piece of
information
but i believe this increase is all tied
up with the renegotiation that was done
with serco
to extend the contract so as part of
that renegotiation there was a
an agreed increase to the contract and
the payments that we
make and there are also usually annual
increases because of the number of homes
are obviously increasing in the district
as well
so as part of the the contract terms
then
obviously we have to pay circo more
because they're collecting from more
more properties
on our behalf so i think there's sort of
a couple of couple of elements in there
in terms of that increase yeah sort of
volume and price
that's it yes thank you okay
thank you very much thank you councillor
carter
yes regards that increase is that
circova also collect
our brown bins because as we may have
noted that our brown bin
due to covered has been uh suspended
so they're actually collecting less than
what they would be
prior to these negotiations is that
represented
um is there any leeway without regards
to the
cost and you're
correct that we have uh had to suspend
the collection of the the garden waste
service uh this week
due to sickness amongst the the crews at
circo
um unfortunately one of the guidance
that we had very early on in terms of
covered with contractors
is that we should continue to to pay
them
at the contracted level um there are
sort of
other mechanisms that government have
been using to compensate
various businesses or councils from
losses through covid
so there was quite a strong steer from
the government back in march
that we should continue to to support
our contractors in terms of what we are
contracted to pay to them so i don't
think we'll be seeing a reduction in
what we pay to serco because of of this
suspension at the moment thank you
councillor casting we're still in
questions uh councillor castin
thank you very much um in regards to the
um
transport page 23 the um conversion
to vegetable oil of the um fleet
it's um it's says
an increase in running costs of 88 000
have we also
looked at the cost of the tanks and the
infrastructure that we need to
um to run those um vehicles on um
vegetable oil in there i couldn't find
that in here
my understanding is that the cost of the
tank which is 50 000
for each site which is the capital cost
will come out the capital programme but
i believe it's
the intention is to actually fund that
through this hill contribution
because it's a important infrastructure
project
okay yeah great anything further
councillor casten
no no that's me thanks counselor eggping
young
uh your hand is still up do you do you
have a further question
i i just have a couple of quick
questions on the capital program chair
if i may
certainly okay so uh i think it's on
page 21 the draft capital program
um i i have a query what is
the md homes grant that is
capitalized there what is that for
i i might be able to have a good girl
answering the question but as i have my
colleague gavin fisk here on from the
housing side perhaps i'll just invite
him as to whether he might want to
answer that question
thank you catherine and thank you
members um the mb homes grants are
obviously grants used by the private
sector housing team
to encourage and support the
maximization of private rented homes
for use and occupation so grants can be
offered
to incentivize for a range of ways
for example improvements to the homes in
order for them to be
habitable and um and and safe uh as
well as others
okay thank you very much gavin um and
then my last question
uh is with regard to the um
ev charging points i see that um we're
we're not planning any further
investment in future yes and i just
wondered whether
uh that's actually the case or or with
or that is that appearing somewhere else
i thought we were going to be
doing quite some a lot of work on
electric charging points
i'll try to answer that question but it
might be one we need to come back to you
um obviously cassandra clements is
leading on the climate change action
plan that we've got
in place and i'm not 100 sure what more
is planned
um i think there's a lot of aspiration
within that programme but we haven't
perhaps built it into
the the capital program at this stage
because nothing further has been brought
forward and costed
and agreed for inclusion but there might
well be
further you know further aspiration to
to increase that
but i think i probably need to go and
check that with uh cassandra and come
back to you
but the reality is that we put half a
million aside last year we'll put
in this coming budget we're also putting
another half million aside to show that
you know
our serious intent in terms of this
climate change and
biodiversity um policy that we have
in indeed council i had and i just was
wondering whether in fact
the the funding for electric
charging points for example would come
out of that fund or would appear
as a separate fund in the capital budget
then
all right i think we just need that
clarifying yeah
okay thank you councillor muller thank
you chair
um hopefully it's okay it's just a
comment really on the question
raised by councillor caston regarding
the um
the the vegetable oil used at the waste
center i was actually at a meeting two
nights ago and this is actually
subject to a sealed bid so i can confirm
that's what it is
thank you chair thank you are there any
further questions
right there being no further questions
i'll open the item for debate
um so
this is really an opportunity for us to
identify areas where we might need
or we think that council might benefit
from having further clarification
it's not an opportunity really for us to
um to make political points we'll have
that opportunity at council
so bearing that in mind
and each of the councillors will have
one opportunity to speak
during this debate could i call on
councillor carter to speak first please
certainly could if i could reach your
unmute button
right um
looking at this and one thing we can all
agree on
is we have a lot of uncertainty coming
in the future
um regardless
it's at a moment it's a very uh
hopeful that we can stick to this
should further shortfall
but i've got a i haven't really got any
comments to make at
this point thank you very much
councillor carter
councillor caston please
yes thank you very much yeah i'm pleased
to see it looks like a um
a well managed um piece of work and um
and nice and clear i think um um
councillor wellam has um brought up a
few little tweaks
maybe that that the document needs but
i'm nothing too serious
um counselor ek pinyong um
said about the um he talked a little bit
about the criteria
um for what falls into the biodiversity
um fund and what falls into other things
and that would be helpful to just be a
little bit clearer on
those kind of things because it that is
quite crucial going forward in the um
for the climate um changing biodiversity
side of things
um but yeah good piece of work i'm
it's good to see thank you councillor
caston
uh councillor muller thank you chair
no uh like councillor casten has said
and also comments made by other other
colleagues
um i think it's an excellent piece of
work and and i have no other other
comments to make at this stage thank you
chair
thank you councillor mueller councillor
ek pinyon
uh thank you chair uh well i would echo
councillor casten's comments i think the
the various points of clarification that
were sought during the earlier part of
this
discussion well worth pursuing
prior to council i would say that this
budgeting exercise appears to me to
continue the
the well trodden path that we have taken
in previous years and it's a a very
sound
document given the circumstances in
which this particular
budget has has to be prepared and
i think you know it shows a a high
degree
of financial prudence which is our our
hallmark so
i i certainly would have no issue
commending this this report
i i do think some of the comparison
charts do need to be looked at again
because i think
the way they're presented is misleading
and certainly if we're doing comparison
charts
comparison shots ought to appear on the
same page rather on
separate pages to make it easier to
follow the comparison
so aside from that i would echo my
fellow councillors in commending this
piece of work thank you
thank you councillor young councillor
scarf
i don't have any further questions uh or
comments to make i think it's
it's a well well prepared report with
the the comments that other councillors
have made prior to me
thank you very much i would just like to
raise one thing
um and and that is really it's under uh
that's on page 15 it's under um the
principles on pay
on paragraph 6.4 and 6.5
and what the focus is on um and the
reason i raise this is i've got a
concern about staff
welfare and i would have liked to have
seen something
about that in the overarching principles
i think we have a
clearly we have a duty to protect our
staff and
and that's been particularly the case um
through the pandemic
um and hopefully we will be moving
towards
a new normal during 21-22
so um protecting our staff and
particularly
the mental health of our staff is vital
and i just wonder
if you consider that to be
covered elsewhere in what we do or
whether
that is sufficiently important for it to
be included in the
overarching principles
yeah please do yeah well i totally agree
with what you're saying i mean
we if it just if we look at the um
weekly um working together that our ceo
puts out
then i mean throughout that the the uh
um concern for staff welfare just comes
through in in abundance
i mean it's from the top down there's
ethos of recognizing that the uh the
difficulties that staff are working
under the fact that
they're probably trying to do child care
whilst also doing the day job
and it's quite clear there it is saying
that staff welfare and the priorities
they've got to put family first so i
think um
there's definitely that ethos throughout
the organization but
i think we could put some wording into
six
four six five to cover that as well i
would
i would like that to be considered
because yes we see
we see a lot of internal documentation
and it's absolutely clear
that the staff staffs mental health is
being looked after but
i i would just like to see in a public
document
if that is or at least i'd like to see
see
consider putting into a public document
so that it's
it's up there and everybody can see that
that it is important absolutely and of
course this
this thing is being streamed to the
world as we speak
right well i've i've got no other no
other comments yes i think it's a
comprehensive document i think we've
suggested one or two
bits and pieces to fine-tune it
so we do we do need now to
to move on to
a recommendation that we can send
to cabinet um
and in in past years the the sort of
recommendation that we have
we have put is to to to ask cabinet to
give due consideration to the comments
that we've made at the meeting
um so is that the sort of thing
i think really um counselor egg pinyon
was suggesting something along those
lines
um uh is that the sort of the sort of
recommendation the sort of proposal that
that we might like to consider
counsellor muller thank you chair no i
totally agree what you say on that i
think that's a very good point and we we
could hopefully add that to the
recommendations
on page seven thank you chair
i think the recommendations on page
seven are the recommendations to
cabinet rather than the recommendations
to us
so i don't necessarily think it's a case
of
us adding our recommendation to their
record
those recommendations i think it's more
that we
we would come up with a specific
recommendation
from this committee
perhaps something along the lines of
overview and scrutiny committee
uh have asked officers and cabinet to
take into consideration
the comments made at this meeting when
submitting the budget to cabinet
and for consideration at council in due
course or in february 2021
something along those lines
sorry yeah no please go ahead
uh counselor casting
well uh what i wanted to say is if if
you're proposing that which um
i would be quite happy to second that
but i it might might be worth um
listening to what henriette's got to say
next um
because i think she was she was just
about to come in well
yes i mean i would like to suggest that
and perhaps um
members consider consider putting those
words
if they're happy with those words into
some sort of uh
some sort of recommendation but
henriette so
chair um we we could sort of say that
the over your exclusion you have asked
officer to
and cabinet members take into
consideration the
uh just one moment chair i'll come back
to you in a minute just let me just
work on this right
uh thank you chip um
i i i fully agree with the thrust of
your
the recommendation you're proposing i
guess really it's all
a matter of asking uh officers and
and cabinet to effectively
uh update the document in the light of
the suggested commentary that we've made
before it goes back to cabinet and and
council in due course
yeah maybe something along those lines
would
deal with it so
so that the over your scrutiny committee
asked that officers and cabinet take
into consideration made at this meeting
uh when submitting the general fund
budget 2021 and four-year outlook
for consideration at the cabinet meeting
in february 2021
is that is that
sorry and council cabinet cabinet and
council in february 2021
yes so into consideration at the cabinet
meeting and council
in february 2021
is that agreeable
i wonder if you would might to repeat
that please henriette i can try and put
it in the chat
would that help everyone okay
see if i can succeed this time
chair uh yes councillor whitehead
yeah if i might be so bold over and
above the
figures you have uh in front of you at
the moment i did say my introduction
that we were
as a cabinet considering putting more
money aside for both
planning legal costs and planning
enforcement costs so that we could
robustly defend a planning application
is going to appeal
and put some money behind our
enforcement team as well so
whether you you as a scrutiny committee
either agree or disagree to that it be
might be helpful
and those were funds from
the um surplus at the end of the current
financial year
no it's well it's allocating funds next
year
yeah that's right yeah from next year's
projected surplus
to actually sort of ring fence those for
those particular reasons
which would effectively bring the cer
you know
surplus down by the figures
and then specifically legal costs
associated
with with planning that's correct yes
my understanding at the moment is the
cabinet members are
happy to do that on the revised document
but um just insofar as the next document
that comes forward to be somewhat
different
slightly different to what you're seeing
now it's if you want if you care to
endorse that
or not
um can i ask a question of henrietta
yes you're uh reading the comment in the
chat which seems
uh a good overarching comment um
and i guess the this is going to be
supported by actual
detail of the the various comments and
and taking account all sort of uh
councillor whiteheads common regarding
the
legal uh and planning expenses
yes i can uh i can include that in the
minutes we will usually send
the recommendations and a copy of the
drafts minutes
to both cabinet and council um to
include in their consideration
at their cabinet meeting and council
meeting
okay thank you would you prefer a
specific
reference to a recommendation for the
funding to be allocated for legal costs
associated with planning
i i think that would be appropriate
given the significance of it
okay so um cancer willem i got sort of
word and it's very basic
that the overview and scrutiny ask that
the cabinet consider
uh that funding be allocated for legal
costs associated with
planning
um i think planning planning enforcement
and the legal costs associated with
planning
okay are we going to put it in full
planning and when um councillor
whitehead when you
talk about planning do you mean um
development management or anything to do
with planning including
playing policy no it's particularly sort
of
you know when we when we have to go to
appeal yeah to make sure we have the
robust finances behind it so that we can
to to to robustly defend um
um decisions that have been taken by
planning committees
chair would you read what you have so we
can see
that the overview and scrutiny committee
asked that cabinet consider that funding
be allocated for planning enforcement
and legal costs associated with planning
planning and enforcement and legal costs
associated
with with planning or specifically
planning appeals
i think we'll leave we could leave it
open do you think councilwrapping
younger
you were
sorry i'll take my hand down um yeah i'm
happy with that as long as councillor
whitehead's happy with it
well it's your committee but yeah well i
mean certainly sorry i'm sorry can i
just interrupt here
can i interrupt here and um let's let's
uh move on please
if you don't mind counseling
[Laughter]
um right are there any i saw a hand
raised it's gone again
um
yeah i just wanted to say yeah league i
think legal costs is the important part
of that and
i don't think we need to add any more to
that um i'm very happy with that
recommendation
right so
we've got something else in there we've
got something else in there
that the overview and scrutiny committee
asked that cabinet consideration
be given for funding to be allocated for
planning enforcement
and legal costs associated with planning
yeah so if i go back to counselor ek
ping young
and councillor caston are you
between you content to um to
propose and second something along those
lines or even that those specific words
uh i'm happy to uh propose something
along those lines uh
chair thank you and councillor caston
yeah i'm happy to second it as it's
written in the comments
so we will now we'll now move on to
an electronic vote um and yeah
um are we going to take the words as
they are in the chat or is somebody
going to
um type them into the um
the relevant pages the relevant line on
um
so chair i think we'll take the words as
there are in a chat for
um you know to save time and so that
the uh vote will be to approve the
recommendations as read by the
governance officer would you like me to
read them again
for clarity or are you happy for them to
be there in the chat
i think they're in the chat i think
we're all happy
are we not
right i am
so can i ask members to um cast their
their vote please in the modern.gov
so chair that is now completed and it's
unanimous
you very much
thank you council of field we will we
will put it we will put it into english
so we are now ready to move on
right we're now we're now ready to move
on i believe to
the draft housing revenue account and
the 21 22 budget and four year outlook
for housing
so um am i right that
um councillor uh whitehead is going to
introduce this report
that's correct if i may i'm happy to
give a few words of
background thank you right yes so for
the year 2122
um we're forecasting a surplus on the
hra 116
000 and this contrasts with the large
deficit we had forecast
or budgeted for the previous year but
members will recall that primarily due
to a slippage in our capital program
we're now forecasting an out turn
surplus also
in 2021 and the table in paragraph 5.2
compares the budgets for the two years
with explanations behind the various
line movements set out in detail
in paragraph 5.5 and savings
efficiencies have been identified during
a robust
budget setting process as set out and
explained in the report
i'd like to take this opportunity as i
did at cabinet to give members some more
background to the proposed
council house rent increase in april 20
we increased our council house rents by
2.7 percent
which was the consumer price index at
the time plus an additional one percent
this was our first increase after four
years of a centrally
government-imposed reduction of one
percent each year
now for the coming year from first of
april 2021
an increase based on september cpi plus
one percent
works out to be only 1.5 percent
and the net effect of these decreases
and increases over a six year period
is that our average council house weekly
rent in march
22 will be only 11 pence higher
than it was in march 2016 so in other
words every six year period
period virtually unchanged
well we'll not be change changing our
sheltered housing utility charges in
2122.
there is an element of subsidy presently
built into these charges
but we have seen some reductions in the
price of gas electric
and especially oil we can therefore
freeze these utility prices for the
coming year
while still making some reduction in the
level of subsidy
and i'm sure members president will also
recall we did not increase
sheltered housing service charges in
this current year
now there remains an element of the
subsidy with these charges and to
eliminate the subsidy in 2122
we'd need to increase service charges by
two pound ninety
but we're not proposing to make such an
increase and the recommendation
is actually just for an increase of one
pound a week
and as i said at cabinets my sincere
hope we can find
cross-party support for such a modest
increase particularly as it follows on
from two years
of zero increase and members should
particularly note in paragraph
5.5 that we intend to develop a rented
service charge policy
for our sheltered housing during 2021
with a view to bringing it into effect
for 22 23 onwards and just turn into
capital
members will see that with an ambitious
program of capital for the four years
from 21 to 25
we've identified development sites for
254 affordable homes
119 shared ownership homes and the new
build and acquisitions
of forecaster costs 42.2 million
and our housing maintenance program to
cost a 15.8 million
and appendix a shows how we intend to
finance this
ambitious capital program but finally
i'd like to draw members attention to i
consider it one of the most important
paragraphs
in this report which is paragraph 4.2
this explains how we'll be reviewing our
30-year business
hr business plan to incorporate new
build specifications
the design guide environmental retrofit
improvements
and new safety enhancements and this new
business plan
will be articulating our vision for
council housing and we'll be coming to
cabinet this summer
so just in closing i'll repeat what i
said in my introduction the uh
we do value this overview and scrutiny
process and welcome any questions
committee members may have
and between myself and the finance
officers we'll do our best to answer
those
thank you thank you very much um
we'll go to to members for questions
then
um councillor carter would you like to
kick off please with a question
uh yes just a quick query a couple
queries
um i may have missed when they're
talking about
the uh the increase in
gas costs and things like that um as a
council turn up myself
i pay my cost to the supplier how would
we
cap this and prevent any further
if we are capping this how are we
preventing increases
that are being charged by the supplier
such as
uh well like that and also
regards um i do realize it is a
only 11 pence a month increase
which we haven't increased in that form
of years yet
this this year the difficulties
in paying rents that have been charged
by the amount of people who have been
either lost work or who
are claiming or lost expenses when they
are
which is not going particularly well
any increase at the moment is a wise
thing to do
is it going to be uh would it put people
who are already struggling
11 pence could that break the camel's
back as well
to start with the question on utilities
that i mean the comments i'm making were
specifically in terms of the sheltered
housing as opposed to
the general tenancy um because
as my understanding those are collected
and paid centrally
um whereas as my understanding is for
the general counsel house tennis
such as yourself you you do do your own
negotiations with
um your utility suppliers but if if
gavin wants to sort of add
anything to that before we move on to
the the question about castle house
rents
gavin would you like to add to that
please
ah thank you chair um i don't really
have anything to to
add to council whitehead's comments just
to confirm and clarify
that when we're talking about uh the
cost of utilities we are talking about
those sites where
we have sherwood housing and we have um
communal facilities there for
for example a communal um meter uh which
obviously administers
uh for for everyone on site if i could
just um
add to the second question before um you
may go back to council whitehead
um councillor cotter was talking about a
uh eleven percent
um eleven p increase i just wanted to um
advise members that actually as a
landlord
um we do uh so much to try and support
our tenants in in being able to maintain
their homes
um and i just point to that the rent
advice that we provide the debt advice
that we provide
and the additional tenancy support in
order to
ensure that tenants wherever possible
can flourish in their tendencies
uh rather than be hampered and in
response to the covert pandemic
um even before national government came
out to say
that there would be an evictions ban um
nationally uh against all ten years as a
result of kovid
baber and mid-suffolk had already made
the decision and had already announced
publicly
that no tenant um who was impacted by
covid in terms of loss of earnings
uh losing job unable to pay rent would
ultimately be evicted for that reason
and that reason alone
so um i think that just uh demonstrates
the
the uh the the landlord that we are um
and the support that we provide to our
tenants
yeah and i just like if i may just add
as well i mean the important thing
members to realize is that the
housing revenue account is a totally
ring fenced account
which is neither subsidised one way or
the other general fund or vice versa
and then basically that's why we do this
sort of certio business plan to ensure
that
um over a long term period this is a
sustainable
um proposition which is why it's
it's a difficult balance when it comes
to increasing capital house rents
but the reality is that if we are to do
achieve what we want to do in things
like
retrofitting and improvements to uh
such things as um you know for climate
change
and to increase the sustainability of
our properties going forward
it's that difficult balancing act and
uh but um i think i think it was 11
pence a week i believe
yeah was it was a figure i quoted that's
just an
average but it's sort of indicative you
know 11 pence on
something like 83 pound average weekly
rent over a six week
six year period is a very very small
uh percentage increase thank you
councillor carter are you are you
content with the response or
um i don't want i don't want to make a
statement we're not in debate
is it a question on the on the report
um i'll leave it for now until debate
thank you
thank you very much um
councillor ekpinyong would you like to
ask a question
do you have any questions please
i i don't have any questions at this
moment thank you chair
uh councillor muller do you have any
questions uh
no questions at present thank you chair
and
councillor scarf do you have any
questions uh yes chair
a couple on on page 39 we talk about the
right to buy
sales um and under 5.17 we talk
the the money received from right to buy
sales can only be used
as a 30 contribution towards the cost of
a replacement home
the remaining 70 has to be funded from
other hra sources
and so my question would be what happens
to the 70
that we don't get from the sale of a
asset which belongs to the authority
that would be the first question i do
have a further one perhaps gavin will be
able to answer the first one
yes if gavin or catherine could i mean i
do understand that
although we talk about 30 70 there are
some occasions where it's 50 50 but
um if gavin or catherine could perhaps
give a more detailed response
chair i'm happy to to confirm that
whilst we
uh receive obviously a a value
um for the property um uh a significant
amount of that um is returned
um to uh government so um
we we only are able to retain uh a
certain percentage of the
the actual receipt i know that might
sound strange and
and um but that has been the case uh for
for a very very long time um and hence
why when we
use the thirty percent um value um the
right to buy receipts that we have
we obviously then have to match fund
that with uh funding from
our capital program
thank you and and and alongside that
a recommendation 3.7 is that that 30
percent should be retained
to um enable continued development and
acquisition of new council
properties um second question then chair
yes along the same along the same
subject on the right to
to buy um we talk about
in um 5.18
um about the restrictions imposed by
covid causing serious delays
to the council's um housing development
program
and its ability to spend all of the
receipts so that's presumably the 30
percent that we've got
um if we fail to spend those receipts
we're told within a three-year period we
must then repay that money to government
with four percent above the base rate
interest added
under 5.19
it tells us that officers have been
focusing on an alternative program to
achieve the spend
by purchasing existing houses and
suitable land from the open market
before the march
2021 extension which the government has
given us ends
and these actions will minimize any
repayments that may be due
back to the government are the officers
confident that we can actually
eradicate any money that we would
actually pay back to the government
because i think that
the idea of us paying back any receipt
and four percent above the base rate is
is
absolutely remarkable so our officer is
confident that we can achieve that
through that alternative program
thank you chair thank you gavin
yeah if i can respond um the assets and
investments team
uh under the leadership of emily attack
have been uh very focused on spending
our right to buy receipts and um it is
fortunate that the government
have extended it we were expecting them
to extend it just because
the house market has uh has has slowed
um and obviously during the first
lockdown we faced the challenge that
um whilst our staff were at work other
conveyances
um legal firms estate agents were
closed for some time um so we do expect
us to be able to spend all of our right
to buy receipts
uh for this year uh by the the march
deadline
obviously we then roll on and we move
into the next financial year
and we have a an amount that we will
need to spend
and some of the work that we are doing
uh working with the assets investment
team is
trying to spend those receipts in
advance so
what you can do is rather than wait for
the quarter or the year that you have to
spend those receipts
by actually you can get upstream of that
and you can spend
the receipts in advance and that's the
work that we are
are doing uh through our capital program
through our acquisitions and
and purchases and build program to to
get up
upstream of that in order for us to
always have a buffer
i think what you will find currently
with the amount of right to buy receipts
that we have
we're obviously have a period of time to
spend
it and that's on the back of what was
traditionally
quite high numbers of council houses
being sold
the reality now and the reality over
probably the last 18 months two years
has actually been a significant
decline in the number of uh right to buy
purchases probably just a symptom or a
sign
of the the economic nature of the
country
putting covert to to one side so in
future we will have less receipts to
to to spend um and the only other point
to make was that um
uh the the rules and and as councillor
scoffers
has described um the the payback and the
additional percentage
is national it does affect all housing
providers
the government did consult all local
authorities going back
probably now nearly two and a half
years on changes to right to buy
legislation
and the for example the length of period
councils have to
spend receipts we did respond to that
consultation
um unfortunately um probably due to
brexit and other reasons
government haven't got to to actually
releasing a white paper or less
if let's change it so we do keep
actively
looking for potentially any changes the
government may make to that process
thank you councillor scarf did you want
to come back with another question
uh not a question but just thank you for
the clarification because i think it's
tremendously useful i was just
my concern was that we didn't pay any
money back to the government over this
because i think it really is
totally wrong um and so i'm very
encouraged by gavin's
answer that they will actually achieve
the spend and that we won't be paying
any money back
nor will we be paying any interest above
the base rate either
and that base rate um and the interest
at four percent i think is quite
ridiculous
but i mean that's a political point but
i'm just pleased that we will not be
paying any money back and that we
we have looked at those alternative
sources of spending that money
um within this section because i think
that's very imaginative
and and would welcome that as a comment
thank you very much councillor scarf
um councillor carter and then i'm going
to move on to councillor field he's
attending and he has his hand up
councillor carter
very sorry i can't seem to keep my
flaming hand down just like in real life
at the moment
um just a very quick
query um going back to the uh point on
the
increase in gas we're not raising
the money to our
shelter tenants yet we are raising the
money to
our other tenants it's just a um
i'll be reflecting that i'll be stating
that to
making it clear that it's necessary um
i'm not against it i do realize that if
this is necessary we should have done it
in previous years as well
i just don't want it reflecting or
anyone taking it out of context
in
or get words out enough would help um i
don't want it being taken out of context
or
have any reflections coming across us in
the future i do realize how
what type of landlords we are i do
realize that
i'm just playing devil's advocate how
how it could be played and how it could
uh
be taken out um
in future and i will try to turn my mic
off and try to
turn my hand down as well would help or
somebody could do it for me i'd
appreciate it
gavin did you have um to make them on
what council carter said please um if
i've interpreted uh
councillor carter's question um the 11p
per week
uh average increase on rents is for all
uh tenants of mid suffix so that's uh
tenure
in terms of general needs tenants living
in their own home
with their own front door as well as
sheltered housing tenants living in
a sheltered housing complex where
there's a communal front door and then
they have their own front door
so um just to clarify 11p is for all
tenants
uh of mid-suffolk um the utility charges
are just for those that are living in
communal accommodation
where there is communal metering um as
such
thank you very much gavin councillor
field
thank you chair for taking questions
from visitors
um two things i think
one pretty simple firstly just
thinking about the um utility charges to
sheltered tenants i
am aware that many sheltered housing
complexes have solar panels fitted
and clearly they're paid for by the
council and
uh the um crawl from export tariff will
go to the council
i just wondered whether the tenants
actually get
the power that is generated supplied to
them
for free in the way that other council
tenants do
and does that therefore act as a
reduction
essentially in their utility charges
so that's question one uh
question two is just uh perhaps to
to uh see how whether i am as ignorant
as i think i might be
the issue about the 30 restriction on
right to buy
i understood uh that the 30
is the amount of money you may use for
new housing
which comes from a right to buy
sale therefore it's a government ploy
to force you to go and borrow
70 extra for every 30 percent you get
and therefore build three times as many
houses roughly as you otherwise
would um is that a correct
interpretation and not perhaps of the
government's underlying motive but at
least of the way it works
thank you
gavin can you take those two questions
please
um yeah happy to take the first one the
answer obvious answer is yes
um just to to clarify that um
where we have sites with um solar pv
um on our larger uh sheltered housing
complexes
um there will be a benefit to tenants in
terms of
electricity being generated during the
day um that isn't going back into
to the grid and then yes in terms of
obviously
any fit received and conscious this is
different or separate to
the solar pv program that the council
undertook in 2014-15
to general needs tenants um actually
um the benefit in terms of any fit
received will be recycled through
the sheltered housing so um currently we
will look
at appalling in terms of uh for example
around utility benefits so where you've
got a large scheme with a large ray on
um that the benefit doesn't all go to
that scheme in terms of
uh the cost of utilities we obviously
look to to
to to pull that across our housing
sheltered housing stock so that everyone
receives a small amount of the benefit
and in answer to the second question
um the answer is is is yes
in yes you are correct council field
that
we recycle a maximum of 30 percent of
the receipts and
yes we will need to find additional uh
uh capital uh to to supplement that in
order to
uh fulfill the requirement to buy a
property so
yes in that in that regard it does it it
does cause us that the challenge that we
need to find
money is to uh add to that 30 percent
yeah but i think we should add that
that 70 is not necessarily all borrowing
which i think is what councillor field
was implying
i mean we we do take we can tell from
the capital
which a capital appendix shows how the
funding comes through and
part of it is you know a large part of
it is borrowing but
other parts come from revenue
contribution and brought forward
reserves et cetera so this and section
106 and
all sorts of various other ways of
funding as well as
borrowing thank you thank you could i
yeah i wasn't questioning um the wisdom
or otherwise of borrowing
clearly there are government schemes
that you can get finance from as well
which
which is all good um the the the real
thing i was just seeking to be sure is
that
you sell a house
i'm not absolutely sure it sort of
sounds as though we only get
30 percent of the value of the house we
sell you know the which is discounted on
market value
i'm absolutely sure i'm right there but
in addition of the money you gain
however you gain it you may only put
30 percent of the cost of building a new
house and you have to borrow
or get from revenue or whatever 70
percent of the cost of building that new
house
so there seems to be a lever to make us
build some more
so so that was again my sort of
ignorance
just so i'm pleased to hear about the um
solar arrays
i'm not sure whether our arrays are
fully instrumented so we know what we
generate what we export what we use
locally but uh
if we are recycling that money into the
you know the benefit of the tenants that
does seem an excellent thing to be doing
thank you thank you
can i just say that i i do share
counselor feels confusion because my
understanding was that with the right to
buy receipts from the sale of a house
that goes into a pot but we can but when
we then we
reuse it we have to sort of make that
that figure up from
a 30 level to 100 level by
which is effectively more than double
but by
financing it but i think we might need
to get clarification on that outside of
the meeting
catherine you have your hand raised
yep i was just going to try and add just
a a little bit that might help to
clarify in terms of
the right to buy receipts when a
property is sold
again there are differing rules
depending on
which property it is because the
government allows us to have an
assumed number of right to buys in our
business plan
and i believe some of those we can
actually keep a hundred percent of the
receipt
but quite often we only get to keep 25
of the actual value of the property
that's sold so again there are different
percentages
that are applied to different right to
buy
sales so it is a it's a complicated
system thank you
so are there any more questions please
if not i will move on to
debate um so the items now open for
debate
you have one opportunity to speak each
and i will come first to councillor
carter
would it be possible to come back to me
after other people have spoken please
okay certainly councillor casten
yeah thank you very much i yeah the
there is a small increase in these
these rents and the from a sheltered
housing
point of view um i don't i think it's
it's probably more good housekeeping
than
um hiking rents to um
for for income it's um it seems sensible
i still think they represent good value
for money
um as a whole um
so yeah i think i i think that's that's
acceptable the um
we talked a bit about um right well
quite a lot about right to buy and um
i think um i i i don't want to get too
political but i don't think um
it it necessarily needs to all add up on
paper
right to buy um system and i think maybe
it does
the council does have to put something
in um there's a lot of
leg ups that people get outside the
council tenants don't necessarily get
like um
you know rich parents and um that sort
of thing
so um i think um i i don't have any
problem whatsoever
if the council has to provide 70
to um to replace that house to um for
the um
social aspect of it but no yeah good
another another good report and um yeah
i'm i'm happy with it i'm
eager to listen to debate
thank you very much thank you councillor
casting councillor muller
thank you chair no i i totally agree
with what uh councillor castle has just
said
and i too think this is an excellent
report i think the 11 p
increase is really negligible we haven't
increased it for a couple of years with
sheltered housing etc
so fully support that no other comments
really share thank you
thank you councillor ek pinyong please
uh thank you chair uh i think um as
others have said it's
it's a good report and well constructed
and
uh the arguments for making the changes
are well thought through
uh and and definitely has my support i'm
particularly pleased to see the
commitment to
the continuing effort to build more
council housing going forward
and uh i think that something that we
need to do
and we need to do more officer i'm
really pleased to see that being given
uh due attention so that's all i would
have liked to say at this point
thank you very much um councillor scarf
well thank you chair yeah sorry to come
back to the um
situation about right to buy receipts
but i i really do
think um there is a problem there i mean
obviously the government is trying to
encourage us to build more houses but
one way to do that would be to
allow local authorities to actually keep
100 of the receipt
providing they used it on providing more
social housing for their benefit of
their residence and
i know it's a political point but i just
can't get my head around the fact that
you know
we we've never been able to keep 100
percent of the receipt
they are an asset of the community and
if we reinvested in
uh the community by building more houses
which i'm sure we would be prepared to
do
by keeping the whole receipt then that
could only benefit everyone in the
community and everyone on our
housing waiting list but other than that
i think the report is
self-explanatory um i think the rent
increase
uh reasoning uh for an increase is
understandable bearing in mind that
uh we've actually had a decrease in rent
for tenants for a period of years
i think it's modest and and affordable
so i
you know i think it's a good report
thank you chair thank you very much
uh councillor carter
uh yes i'm happy to echo the um the
comments made by
a councillor scarf before me um i do
also agree it's a well thought out
report and i do agree that the eleven
percent is
it the eleven pence it's a it's a
it's a reasonable increase it's just
unfortunate it's done this year and
hadn't been implemented in the four
years but we can't we haven't got a
crystal ball to know what's coming up
um and also i do agree fully but uh if
we had 100
to invest into social housing we would
be getting more of an investment back
doing more of a benefit to our community
in fact but that's i guess that's a
political point and uh
it's not for today's uh not for today's
meeting thank you very much
thank you um the council of whitehead
has a a comment to make and then
can can members of the committee start
thinking about
um any recommendations that they would
like to make a proposal and
uh and not for a second to please
council whitehead
yes thank you chair sorry i think i
might have caused some confusion in my
introduction because the increase
weekly increasing a council house rent
on average will be
well average will be one pound 25 pence
a week
what the the contrast i made was that if
you actually work back the increases and
decreases
over the last six years a an average
council house rent now which is
somewhere around
83 pound if you move that back by the
increase in decreases back to six years
that 83 pound would have been something
like 82 pound 89.
so over that's oh for an average house
obviously average house doesn't exist
other than by
averaging uh the the the difference
between over the six years is
11p with ups and downs but just be clear
that the
the recommendation is to increase the
rents by an average of one pound 25
a week and i just think i might have
caused some confusion inadvertently
i apologize for if i haven't yeah i
think that's clear it's one pound 25
a week on average more than last year
but 11 p
more than it it was
six years ago so it's gone down it's
gone up again
it's only just gone past what it was six
years ago and it's gone past that amount
by 11 p a week
on average absolutely on average that's
my understanding
thank you thank you um
so members of committee uh we've we've
we've had a we've had a lot of questions
we've had a bit of a debate
does anybody want to make any sort of
uh recommendation any proposal um
do you want to endorse the budget
proposals and the outlook um do you want
to
ask officers and and cabinet to take
into account the comments that we have
made
um what
would you like to do uh
counselor ek pinyong
thank you chair i think in the light of
the comments that have been made
um i think a simple endorsement of the
report would probably suffice
councillor casting
yeah quite happy to second that i think
um i've been listening to the debate and
um
i i don't think there's any issues that
are
inside of our remit for this um this
scrutiny committee to um
to recommend other than um yeah we would
like
well the proposal that um councillor
ekpanyong
just made
councillor muller thank you chair yes i
too would happily support
the proposal that um council repping
yong has just made
i think it's an excellent paper as i
said previously so i'm more than happy
to support the
recommendation thank you so
um henry yet have you have you got
a a a a bit of an understanding of what
sort of
wording to have something like that over
your scrutiny committee endorsed the
housing something like that yes chair i
i think we follow sort of um
sort of along the same lines before um
so that the overu and security committee
endorses the housing revenue account
2021
22 and four-year outlook are we going to
ask again
to include the minutes to the
recommendations
um for consideration at cabinet and
council
would you like that to be included or
would you just like i mean we'd normally
do that anyway when we send the
recommendation along but would you like
them to be taken into consideration
so um i'll ask the proposer in a second
would you like something included along
the lines that officers and cabinet
take into account the comments made at
this meeting
how would you not feel that's nice i'm
happy for that
to be the case chair okay and the
secondary
um am i the second chairman i think so
yes yeah yeah
yeah no i'm i'm more than happy for
those that to be included
thank you thank you
so um henriette how do you want to
propose
proceed do you want to put something
into the chat box or do you want to read
something out
i have already put something in a chat
box if that's easier for
members to do that but i'm happy to read
it out as well
it is that the overview and security
committee endorses the housing revenue
account budget
20 21 22 and four-year outlook
but asks that officers and cabinets
and cabinet members i think we'll call
it shelby
yeah takes into consideration the
comments made at this meeting when
submitted the budget for
consideration at the cabinet and council
meetings in february 2021
so all we're missing for the one in the
chat box is members cabinet members
is everybody happy with that yes i can't
see anything in the chat box
here at the minute oh oh yes
i was going to say the same thing but uh
what 10 yet says
here we go sorry try again sorry i need
to remember to
press return there we go it's here
so proposer and secretary you're content
with that wordy
indeed mr chairman thank you so can we
then
proceed to the um electronic vote
yes chair and if you go to your
modern.gov app
the vote is now in progress please cast
your votes
um
i'm still missing cancer willem are you
um
having problems with your yes
it hasn't come up on mine right
that's not not to worry counselor well
i'm i can take your vote uh
verbally if you i'm like
yeah i would vote for the proposal
thank you but white hasn't come up i do
not know
so that is uh six vote four so that is
unanimous chair
thank you
right thank you to officers for your
input this morning
that's been really helpful um and you've
got one or two bits and pieces
to take away for future consideration
um we now move on to the review of
the representation on outside bodies an
additional
recommendation
this is this is not for discussion we
had the discussion at the last meeting
and you can see there on page 45 the
recommendation
so so uh do i have somebody who would
like to propose that recommendation
counselor scarf your hand is up
thank you chair yes i'm quite happy to
propose the recommendation as printed
thank you and councillor muller i'm more
than happy to
second count to scarce recommendation as
as it stated thank you
thank you can we then um
conduct the um electronic vote
yes chair thank you if members would
like to cast their vote on the
modern.gov app it is now in
progress
unfortunately i can't get my hand to get
onto modern government i'm going to vote
for if possible please
counsel
thank you it's not a problem
and on my screen it's it's still
only showing that the draft
uh general fund budget the other
nothing has come up since then
right so yeah it's saying that it was
last updated on
at 1107 but it it hasn't
right would you like to cast your vote
verbally yes i will have to yes uh in
favor
thank you so that is six votes four
which means the vote is unanimous chair
thank you very much
we now move on to the um forthcoming
decisions list
do members have any comments on the
forthcoming decisions
please
i didn't have any comments it would
appear nobody has any comments
so the forthcoming decisions list is for
noting
item 10 is the mid suffix overview and
scrutiny work plan
uh has anyone any comments on the work
plan please
no no comments uh if anybody has perhaps
they'd raise their hand but i don't see
any
hands raised so the mid suffolk work
plan is
for noting and that
concludes this meeting thank you very
much thank you to officers who have
attended
and thank you very much members thank
you very much
any meeting and it will be on monday the
15th of february
you